let weaker people complain that the
world isn't fair you are the leader of
your life take ownership of everything
in it that would come home at lunchtime
and instead of having lunch over to 200
sit-ups the little things in life matter
if you can't do the little things right
you'll never be able to do the big
things right want to be happy
build a life not just the business
[Music]
every single day we'll be running it out
so loving you and I believe in life for
oh hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel is created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you to you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
so today let's live your best believed
life and learn seven habits from the
military that will change your life
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one make your bed and while these
lessons were learned during my time in
the military I can assure you that it
matters not whether you ever served a
day in uniform it matters not your
gender your ethnic or religious
background your orientation or your
social status our struggles in this
world are similar and the lessons to
overcome those struggles and to move
forward changing ourselves and changing
the world around us will apply equally
to all every morning
in seal training my instructors who at
the time were all Vietnam veterans would
show up in my barracks room and the
first thing they do is inspect my bed if
you did it right the corners would be
square the covers would be pulled tight
the pillows centered just under the
headboard and the extra blanket folded
neatly at the foot of the rack it was a
simple task mundane at best but every
morning we were required to make our bed
to perfection it seemed a little
ridiculous at the time particularly in
light of the fact that we were aspiring
to be real warriors tough
battle-hardened seals but the wisdom of
this simple act has been proven to me
many times over if you make your bed
every morning you will have accomplished
the first task of the day it will give
you a small sense of pride and it will
encourage you to do another task and
another and another and by the end of
the day that one task completed will
have turned into many tasks completed
making your bed will also reinforce the
fact that the little things in life
matter if you can't do the little things
right you'll never be able to do the big
things right and if by chance you have a
miserable day you will come home to a
bed that is made
but you made and a maid bed gives you
encouragement that tomorrow will be
better so if you want to change the
world start off by making your bed how
about number to take extreme ownership
with jockle willing take ownership of
everything I call this extreme ownership
in the military the best leaders and the
best troops were the ones that took
ownership of everything in their world
not just the things they were
responsible for but for every challenge
and obstacle that impacted their mission
when something went wrong
they cast no blame they made no excuses
they took ownership of the problem and
fixed it you can implement this attitude
as well not only in your job but in your
life let other people blame their
parents their boss or the system let
weaker people complain that the world
isn't fair you are the leader of your
life take ownership of everything in it
how about number three master leadership
skills with Robert Kiyosaki what's your
philosophy when it comes to human
resources how do you get the right
people and then how do you keep the
right people that's the most important
part of business you know that's why I
went to military school and I went to I
was a Marine Corps the reason why when I
talk to military veterans you probably
have the most important skill of all
because all we're trained to do whether
you're the general or private you're
taught to be leaders it is a number one
skill of an entrepreneur is people
skills and leadership skills and
unfortunately most people don't have it
coming into so when I do my talks to
veterans and all this stuff I really
want to encourage them you know because
they're pretty depressed because they
can't get it you know they're low mark
reader which is a good job but they're
afraid to take the leap into
entrepreneurship so but military guys I
don't care what branch of service just
by the indoctrination process and the
survival rate where they go to combat or
not is that you learn leadership skills
people skills you've got to have that
you know whether whether you're a team
of one
you still have to deal your customers
and the good customers bad customers
lawsuits taxes government regulations
and all this they're all people skills
you know so when somebody says to me
what do I need to learn I said boy you'd
better learn how to communicate pretty
quickly to people you don't like and get
them on your side you know how to win
friends and influence people basic book
the number one skill of an entrepreneur
is people skills also if you want to
have more confidence self-love and
motivation check out my 254 series
they're free the link to join are in the
description below people want to know
how to stop the laziness and they will
know how to stop the procrastination
most phd's tell me I can't right yes I
said I can't right but I can't sell it's
about what you're saying to yourself but
it also comes at work so whenever I was
getting beat down physically mentally
spiritually whatever I was going through
just saying you know I would put you
know you can't hurt me how about number
four take risks at least twice a week
the trainees were required to run the
obstacle course the obstacle course
contained 25 obstacles including the
10-foot wall a 30-foot cargo net a
barbed wire crawl to name a few but the
most challenging obstacle was the slide
for life
it had a three-level 30-foot tower at
one end and a one-level tower at the
other in between was a 200-foot long
rope you had to climb the three tiered
tower and once at the top you grab the
rope swung underneath the rope and
pulled yourself hand over hand until you
got to the other end the record for the
obstacle course had stood for years from
my class began in 1977 the record seemed
unbeatable until one day a student
decided to go down the slide for life
headfirst instead of swinging his body
underneath the rope and inching his way
down he bravely mounted the top of the
rope and thrust himself forward it was a
dangerous move seemingly foolish and
fraught with risk failure could be an
injury and being dropped from the course
without hesitation the students slid
down the Rope perilously fast instead of
several minutes it only took him half
that time and by the end of the course
yeah broken the record if you want to
change the world sometimes you have to
slide down the obstacles headfirst habit
number five is manage chaos with Patrick
be David military was all about managing
chaos everything's happening at the same
time you had to find a way to be poised
and you we saw people that couldn't
handle it I remember one of the
exercises that we had right before you
become a graduate is you have to low
crawl under these wires while above you
semi-automatic the semiautomatic weapons
are shooting right above you got that
and that's all you're here it's late
night it's raining its heat it's humid
it's terrible and you're low crawling
with this noise that's chaos you're
panicking you've never been through that
before what do I do
there was a kid on the base that same
day there was a kid on the base that had
to do this he can handle he stood up
boom done deal okay that's kind of like
in business you have all these you feel
like there's so many chaos in business
you don't know how to handle it all of
us and you make one mistake in business
one stupid mistake you lose you into our
business because you don't know how to
manage chaos habit number five be super
driven with Arnold Schwarzenegger my
parents really thought that there was
something terribly wrong of being dead
driven you know because I would come
home at lunchtime and instead of having
lunch over to 200 sit-ups and they were
neither we'll go to the stadium and that
would be lifting weights I will come
home at 10 o'clock at night and there
will be continued lifting weights so it
was like one of this insanity in a
military I will continue lifting weights
no matter how the training was and how
tough the basic training was I would
always then lift weights afterwards and
as a tank driver would have on the side
of the tank in the toolbox I would have
my weights my barbells and dumbbells and
my exercise bench and everything there
in order to be at any given time if we
stopped driving the tank and maneuvers
at 2:00 in the morning I will be able to
pull out my weights and again lift for
two hours my weights as I said I was
really a fanatic about the whole thing
but it's the only way you really get
where the way I succeeded because I
became at the age of 20 at the youngest
mr. universe in London in the history of
bodybuilding
habit number seven the last time before
a very special bonus clip is embrace the
suck with david Goggins when things hit
you in life that you're afraid of or
you're not good at the first thing you
guys say to yourself is why am I here
anyway this isn't for me
the water is too cold the sun's too hot
I'm getting up too early why am i doing
this to myself that's what the normal
mind says I had to start training my
mind to think about how the can I get
through this not giving myself a way out
never give myself creating the wall
around all the [ __ ] ways out in my
mind and a slowly starts to build this
wall so my mind knew this is not gonna
give himself a way out of here in my
first home we had a huge setback I was
broken my legs were broken I had double
pneumonia I got rolled back to day one
week one of Navy SEAL training I got
through that second hell week during the
second hell week I actually broke my
knee I continued to limp around for a
couple weeks I couldn't make it anymore
got rolled back to day one week one I'll
never forget standing there in front of
Captain Bollinger
he was a co in charge of Navy SEAL
training at the time and he had no mercy
on anybody if he believed in managing
your expectations I wouldn't be here
today he challenged me again I was
challenged my whole life not by the
mindset of managing expectations by
exceeding expectations not by managing
them I'm standing there with crutches
I'm sitting in his office he looks at me
he goes jogging this year last time
we're gonna push you through Navy SEAL
training this would be your third hell
week in one year we're not gonna put you
through a 40 so this is your last time
I'm saying thinking how am I gonna get
through this I'm badly jacked up my legs
are broken my knee is messed up
and he goes 'i have a couple of months
to get better a couple months isn't
gonna do it i won't get healed up a
couple of months but i realized i'm
going to get through this
i'm gonna find a way to get through it
cuz why i put barriers in my mind so my
third hell week i went in there with
pretty much I would put a black sock on
first I would get duct tape and I
duct-taped my ankles all the way up to
my calf every single morning then I put
another black sock over it and what that
did that prevented me from moving my
ankle so I didn't really I wasn't
flexing my shin as much and I started
running with just my hip flexors in this
hell week it was a bad Hilary had a guy
died on Thursday morning of hell week I
went on to become a Navy SEAL greatness
is not something that you meet once it's
something that you meet thousands of
times in your life and you don't reach
it if you're not constantly in constant
pursuit of greatness so if my mom were
to say right now I'm great
I just lost we're gonna grow we're not
going to triple down on our strengths
we're not gonna do that crap we're gonna
work on our weaknesses so we grow we
need friction to do that without
friction there's no growth without
friction this confusion confusion is
David God is how did you become who you
are today I put a bunch of friction in
my life
and I grew that's how I did it you know
you get merely tough it's a lifestyle
instead of hitting that snooze button in
the morning and not making your bed not
cleaning your house you don't get this
news button you get up you don't want to
go run you go run you don't want to go
swim and go swim you wanna make your bed
you make your bed you don't wear a kid
in your house to clean your house you
don't want to study study that's how you
start to callus your mind so that became
my life if you say you're gonna wake up
at four o'clock in the morning to go run
wake up at four o'clock and it's gonna
suck
it's not gonna be fun do something that
sucks every single day of your life
that's how you grow embrace the Sun now
I've got a really special bonus clip
that is surprising that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
let's go from just watching the video to
taking action here we go
question going where do you need to
better embrace the suck number two what
do you need to take extreme ownership of
today and number three did you make your
bed this morning and if you made it this
far in the video you're still watching
and you commit to taking action after
watching this video I want to celebrate
you give me a hashtag believe down there
video as well the ninth week of training
is referred to as hell week it is six
days of no sleep constant physical and
mental harassment and one special day at
the mud flats the mud flats are an area
between San Diego and Tijuana where the
water runs off and creates the Tijuana
sloughs a swampy patch of terrain where
the mud will engulf you it is on
Wednesday of hell week that your paddle
down in the mud flats and spend the next
15 hours trying to survive this freezing
cold the howling wind and the incessant
pressure to quit from the instructors as
the Sun began to set that Wednesday
evening my training class having
committed some egregious infraction of
the rules was ordered into the mud the
mud consumed each man till there was
nothing visible but our heads
the instructors told us we could leave
the mud if only five men would quit only
5 mins just five men and we could get
out of the oppressive cold looking
around the mud flat it was apparent that
some students were about to give up it
was still over 8 hours till the Sun came
up 8 more hours of bone-chilling cold a
chattering teeth and shivering moans of
the trainees were so loud it was hard to
hear anything and then one voice began
to echo through the night one voice
raised in song the song was terribly out
of tune
but some with great enthusiasm one voice
became two and two became three and
before long everyone in the class was
singing the instructors threatened us
with more time in the mud if we kept up
the singing but the singing persisted
and somehow the mud seemed a little
warmer and the wind a little tamer and
the dawn not so far away if I have
learned anything in my time traveling
the world it is the power of hope the
power of one person a Washington a
Lincoln King Mandela and even a young
girl from Pakistan Malala one person can
change the world by giving people hope
so if you want to change the world start
singing when you're up to your neck in
mud
if you want to know david Goggins one
simple trick to persevere no matter what
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there self talk
without real work is just a lie yeah so
my self talk is new reminiscing back